hello everybody and welcome to part 13
of let's play penumbra overture as we
left off there was a giant worm a bunch
of other stuff yeah
oh stuff that I didn't care about I'm
Way too brave to be disturbed
Oh finally thank you ah no oh that's a
cruel joke yeah Oh
screwdriver yeah BAM oh yeah and pliers
bolt cutter rather alright I'm so
prepared for anything now all right okay
not worth not worth for you maybe I
would love it shows what you know
all right for the other places now that
doors securitized um what's this I guess
is open now yeah
guess right bring on I'm ready let's go
to shaft 12 shaft 12 here I took doggy
oh boy no no boxes no boxes about
Systema how much this dinner come on
give me a box box come on bring it on
bring it on little doggy
oh is that about nicosia box
I probably shouldn't stand on that ah
barrel perfect barrel you're my safety
barrel I'll remember you actually when
have I ever done something that's
logical I will
so destroy this dog Oh bring it on dog
you are going to be ah miss miss miss
miss uh uh-huh did I get it oh no no no
no no no no no no no
oh yeah barrel jump a big lead moves oh
I didn't even follow me what's going on
here you give up the chase so easily dog
oh yeah oh yeah now you're gonna get it
all yeah bring it bring it
oh come on bring it bring yeah all you
you see me see me bring it boy are two -
I can take two where are you come here
I'll make a noise funk poop on now you
want a funk right in the butt right in
the butt another one friend up Oh miss
oh you want some let's see if I can hit
yeah I can and I will [ __ ] yeah oh poor
doggy killed like ten of your friends
right whatever
they ran away good good
oh no I know I'm a barrel safety barrel
safety borough safety barrel come on I'm
ready for ya oh yeah you want some hey
I'm over here
stupid come on go on
oh yeah I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
I'm ready hey um oh I'm ready
oh you you got so ah I'll miss you don't
run away
I'll be right here bunk sending messages
by tapping into the wall oh yeah come on
oh through the gate on soli oh yeah oh
you're dead now you're dead ran on oh
yeah you want some you all you off
finishing blow oh so hard for oh yeah
oh that's why you like me so much guys
and gals ladies on my way to shaft see
chef 12 sorry chef 12
all right shaft 12 here I come oh come
on that's bullcrap this bullcrap Brad no
let me see what you wrote huh oh no
kidding
uh whatever whatever he doesn't know
John doesn't know Han the refinery I
guess oh right
Oh what's wrong with my framerate I'll
bring it
safety barrel Oh funk gon get some get
some
yeah oh come on hi hi come here young
you're wack walk and ah come on
you're done how's it good done ah come
on weren't you done done now you yep I
win I went again I'm so great
Yeah right refinery oh this door better
not be locked oh thank god but hey
another one
Oh gotta get it from another way why not
the door that's there
Darren I'm deaf I'm sorry sorry sorry
alright this looks cool something going
wrong with my framerate huh I don't know
looks okay come on
inspect it put your eyeball right on
that oh thank you so much
go in here I wonder where it goes
thank you John I was wondering the same
thing
all right
okie-dokie oh man let me get gonna be
time pistol thing where I gotta walk
through
okay I can't click it
WAM long whoo
nope nothing nothing nothing any notes
any thoughts John nope you're a useless
sack Oh
screwdriver we got items maybe I'd use
it ah come on John you can't make it up
some stairs you still pathetic bunk no
ball crush now
close it now I know that
I'll crush every bone in your body if
you don't figure out a way out of here
oh come on how strong am i that I just
jammed it shut on so strong honey didn't
know all right come on let me throw
throw ha ha ha
buttons press the buttons but but but
nope
okay is it cable wires connect those
buttons up that person oh no kid do that
I can't press the buttons won't let me I
got no hand hand who's chopped off and
industrial accident Oh seriously
Mikey oh I see oh the hands not there
but it's still working
ah let's go up those go easy as pie oh
I'm so smart except it's not
I still still ha yeah looking
oh-oh-oh ten billion units of smart
juice all over Oh victory advice thank
you I know him oh shut up Billy the back
of my mind to the fetch mother now power
has returned rocks like a puzzle nearby
fences bond allow for such frivolity
uh-huh this looks important maybe still
there's something to could do about that
what tell me author of a building
contains about charity in the property I
think I know huh well that leaves the
circle
down there oh maybe this goes back bunk
Baba little guy spare motor yeah bunk
let's see comparable close-up not for
long huh huh yeah a worm came through
and when the circle I didn't know yeah
that seems about right
alright this is a loader go let's send
this motor on its way and then it'll go
magically to where I need a kill is it
still locked probably yes oh let me open
it with my strong arms Oh nope yeah Bob
our little guy go go do your destiny oh
I believe in you I believe in you
I just lost an important part in all I
did
I'll go back here see if I missed
anything uh-huh oh oh yeah oh oh so
smart
oh yeah okay get up there I might need
you yeah come here ah try to get you
straight up I know
no don't care uh yeah oh no don't
ah what the hell barrel up barrel barrel
you there we go okay skate you stay yeah
jump jump no all right I got this barrel
and then you stand there I get on barrel
are [ __ ] I get on barrel I grab you and
I put you up here where you're needed
maybe possibly well whatever
all right stop these blades man oh yeah
I knew it oh I'm so smart
Thank You motor to be back to give me a
second here we sorry I didn't mean to
leave you oh right that's good see oh
hello maybe the strong am Kimble
flashlight motor combo most lethal of
all combos oh that time Buch shut up
Oh No did you with my love I know why
your love you could give me with
something it's not gonna be love oh shut
up
uh-huh so smart I brought that huh basil
the horse and Leon hey boss shut up
about horses Hedley only flesh is so
hard to come by oh I'll shut up I knew
your Oliver with a hand of the Potter
scar across Georgia deliver the country
by way of inviting me oh shut up shut up
oh right oh this looks puzzling that
looks good
alright some sort of combination I
actually have to pause it here I will
solve this puzzle in a second
thank you for watching and I'll see you
in part 14 bye-bye